but you know what else is terrifying the
president right now not just the fact
that you know his buddies are going to
jail left and right he is actually
afraid of the investigation taking place
in the Southern District of New York
recently Alan Dershowitz in fact it was
this past Sunday when on ABC's this week
where he said that that investigation is
the one that really should terrify
Donald Trump that is the one that
actually has the power to take down this
administration in a case you haven't
been following along at home
Dershowitz is no anti Trump er all right
this is a guy who every given
opportunity is going to go on Fox News
or any other cable news show and defend
the president and try to say that he is
above the law in fact in the ABC News
interview he also mentioned that Donald
Trump is above the law but here's the
thing if Dershowitz is out there telling
us that Trump should be worried about
this New York investigation and that it
could end his administration probably
something we should be paying attention
to only for the fact that Dershowitz has
done everything possible to defend the
president here's what we know about
these New York investigations CFO Alan Y
Solberg from the Trump Organization has
been given immunity
David pecker National Enquirer has been
given immunity these people know about
payments these people know what Donald
Trump did they have information about
Michael Cohen Cohen with his plea deal
now which we do not necessarily have all
of the specifics of what we do know that
in some way shape or form this man is
cooperating and as part of his
cooperation he also implicated Donald
Trump and two felony offenses but we
also have the Trump charity the Trump
foundation investigation happening right
there where they misused the charitable
funds they use them to try to influence
the campaign which is highly illegal
they used them to pay off some of their
lawsuits which is also illegal you know
basically try to do whatever they could
to treat this Trump Foundation
charitable fund as their personal piggy
bank
and that is what they did so you have
that part of the investigation and as
Dershowitz correctly pointed out on this
interview with Stephanopoulos I believe
it was Trump can't pardon himself from
any of that there is nothing he can do
and as far as the Trump foundation goes
the four people being looked at in that
regard or Trump himself
Donnie jr. Ivanka and Eric so that's the
core Trump family right there and there
is nothing that the president could do
should any one of them be indicted
nothing he cannot pardon them if they
have committed state crimes he can't
interfere he can't intervene that's the
end of it and that's the message that
Dershowitz was trying to send and then
Dershowitz also went on to say something
that is completely untrue and I feel
needs to be addressed he said that the
president has a lot of authority you
know with these federal offenses he may
be facing that he could somehow get out
of them or that he can't be indicted or
that he could pardon himself this is all
nonsense okay there is not a single word
in any law written into the United
States in the Constitution federal law
statutes state law local ordinances
nothing that says that a sitting
president can't be indicted that
actually comes from a Justice Department
memo that suggests the president can't
be indicted now last I checked a memo
from the DOJ isn't a law that's just
their opinion of the people who were
working at the DOJ at the time it would
have to be tested in the courts to see
if there is any constitutionality of it
we also know obviously Supreme Court
made up about half and half right now if
Kavanaugh gets confirmed it's going
solid Republican majority but even then
testing the constitutional limits of the
office of the presidency with regards to
pardoning themselves or whether they can
or cannot be indicted
I disagree firmly with Dershowitz on
this
no one person in this country has ever
been or will ever be above the law and
in order for a court to say that the
president cannot be indicted they would
also have to tacitly be saying the
president is above the law and I don't
care which side of the aisle you fall on
which you know little letter is next to
your voter registration ID you can't
tell me that anyone in this country left
right center and everything in between
is above the law that is a slippery
slope from which we will never crawl our
way out of again the president like
everybody else in this country can be
indicted can be arrested and can be put
in jail there is nothing in any US law
that says otherwise we're gonna take a
quick break but if you want more make
sure you check out David's YouTube page
you can also find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire
and you can follow me on twitter at
baron balanced we'll be right back
today's program is made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman this is
something I really believe in better
help gives you access to fully licensed
and experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer I have been talking for years
about the problem around people not
seeking help because of the stigma
around mental health services because of
the cost of mental health services and
all you have to do with better help is
go to better help calm slash Pakman
answer some basic questions you'll be
matched with a therapist that will be
right for you you can change therapists
if you don't think that it's a good fit
it's less expensive than seeing someone
in person you will still get the
professional help and it is unlimited
you can talk to a therapist every day
from home or wherever you are go to
better help calm slash Pakman it is so
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube
better help calm /pa que ma n if you've
been wanting to talk to somebody but for
whatever reason haven't please go to
better help calm /pa que ma n